[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here
and uh all right it's the one we've all
been waiting for apple held an event
today at their new spaceship campus in
the new steve jobs theater to unveil a
couple things that may or may not have
leaked a little bit beforehand but that
we're excited to finally see in person
so there's a couple low-key smaller
announcements before the big one which
was first of all the new apple tv which
now supports 4k
and hdr we also got to see the new apple
watch series 3 which now has a cellular
connection and can make and take phone
calls so that's all good stuff and we
appreciate that but what we were really
there to see
is the new iphone and what we got was
two new iphones we got iphone 8 and 8
plus and we got iphone 10
not really sure what 9 would be maybe
we're just skipping that all together
that's cool too so iphone 8 and 8 plus
are spec bump to the current iphone 7
and 7 plus so nearly identical design
but it now has the glass back to support
qi wireless charging which is awesome to
see it has a true tone display but the
same sizes and resolutions and a new a11
bionic chip inside and some slightly
updated 12 megapixel cameras and it
comes in a new rose gold color which i
think is more of like a copper or a
faded like sandblasted kind of look so
bottom line this is definitely an
improvement it's an upgrade over what we
currently have but even though this is
called iphone 8 this is definitely more
iphone 7s let's not get it twisted but
then came the one more thing and that
was
iphone 10. don't you dare call it iphone
x it's iphone 10. so this is the phone
that looks like all the dummies and
models i was showing you guys earlier
this year and now seeing in person now
those things those things are
staggeringly accurate so this was my
focus in the time we got to play with
them hopefully i can do them justice on
video so iphone 10 like we expected has
the larger 5.8 inch oled display but in
a smaller body than the other iphones
thanks to the tiny bezels so you have
the display going really close to the
edges of the corners of the display
curving at the edges and then has that
notch in the middle of the top and my
main question when playing with those
early mock-ups was you know how would
apple handle the notch in the display
with the rounded corners well now we
have our answer you get your time on the
left side of it and your signal and
battery on the right side and then
basically depending on what app you're
in the clock and the signal and battery
will turn black or white to contrast
with the background so if you're in a
dark app they turn white if you're in a
white app like apple music or something
they turn black so basically you can
always see them and then certain apps
most of them actually will go full
screen and fill the entire display
around the notch which is really cool
kind of looks like the essential phone
with a much wider notch it gives you
that immersive look but then other apps
a couple maybe watching a video
sometimes you can ignore that top bar
and just show a rectangular aspect ratio
but i guess the goal here is definitely
to be immersive so the whole point of
the display filling up the whole front
of the phone
is that you can fill it any time
possible so developers will be on that
pretty quickly so anytime an app can go
full screen it definitely will and then
the other big question was there's no
home button so how do you go home well
the answer is it's a gesture now so to
go home on the iphone x it's no longer a
button you swipe up from the bottom of
the phone so basically anytime you see
that bar at the bottom that represents
the home swipe and you swipe up to go
home and to get to the multitasking
panel you swipe halfway up so you got to
remember the difference between those
two and then there are three different
swipe down gestures on this phone ready
swipe down from the middle for
notifications swipe down from the right
corner for a control center and swipe
down in the middle of the home screen
for search so basically all these
operations you know interacting with the
phone that are now done on the screen
they're all gestures to make that
possible you can even wake the display
by just touching it once it's a lot to
get used to but i'm willing to give it a
shot it's kind of what you get yourself
into when you remove all the buttons and
then the big story with this phone is
that the front-facing sensors in that
big tab up at the top are really
advanced and they kind of have to be
because apple has replaced touch id and
fingerprints with face id and facial
recognition so i didn't get to test this
much at all yet but i definitely plan on
it because apple's made a big deal out
of it and a lot of big claims about how
reliable it needs to be you know million
to one chance that someone else can get
into it with something other than your
face it needs to be really secure
because it's literally replacing touch
id but that's something i'll have to
test for the full review
now the last major change on the outside
is the new cameras so yes the vertical
camera orientation is new and just like
i always say i think it looks better
here in real life than it did in the
renders and the iphone 10 is rocking
those two slightly updated 12 megapixel
cameras again and this time they're both
optically stabilized so the telephoto
lens should do a bit better have a
better success rate and low light do
better with video etc so obviously photo
and video quality is another thing that
i got to test when i get it but one
thing you'll notice is apple is really
trying to give some more customization
options in their portrait modes i think
that's probably triggered by what
samsung just did with the note8 so now
when you open the portrait mode on the
iphone you will get these extra modes
that will try to adjust the look of the
lighting so you can go from natural
light to studio light to contour light
to even stage light which is really
dramatic and these will also now work
with the front facing camera as well so
you can do portrait mode with the
front-facing camera and mess with all
these camera effects on your face which
you know is going to take your selfie
game to the next level at least i think
so and yeah you can actually change all
this stuff after you've taken the photo
as well so that right there the front
facing camera improvements i mean
honestly is enough reason for some
people to consider getting this phone
hilariously enough so the front-facing
camera will also work great with this
new feature in ios called
animojis which is literally animated
emojis it's like seven or eight emojis
with faces on them that move as you move
so in case you ever wondering what did
the fox say
sorry that's a okay that's a terrible
joke but yeah now an imessage you can
send short videos with your voice coming
from an emoji it's really good at making
people make weird faces not gonna lie
yeah other than that the rest of what's
new with the iphone 10 is the same as
what's new with iphone 8. so spec bump
to the a11 bionic chip so should have
buttery smooth performance the glass
back of course enabling qi wireless
charging which i'm excited to start
seeing everywhere now the oled display
is also now true tone enabled
and yeah it's this this beautiful new
gesture enabled
fingerprinty slab of glass and metal
that will start at a thousand bucks when
it goes on sale in november now are
there concerns with it yes absolutely uh
there's no pro motion display
which isn't really a concern actually
but the brightness of the oled panel was
in question when the specs were revealed
nobody got to take this phone outside or
anything but i can already tell my note
8 display got brighter for what it's
worth
and now the power button on the side is
also a little bit bigger
and you can hold it down to trigger siri
i'm telling you right now that's going
to cause a lot of accidental siri
triggers in pockets around the world for
the next year just throwing that out
there but
whatever i'm glad it's finally revealed
the rumors are over
and this is iphone 10. of course both
these phones the 10 and the 8 and 8 plus
will go under the microscope for the
full review in the next couple weeks and
months so definitely subscribe already
to be the first to see these phones when
they come out but uh i am liking what
i've seen so far i'm really into the 10.
maybe you are too let me know in the
comments below thanks for watching
and i'll talk to you guys the next one
peace
[Music]